فقدت الساحه الفنيه السعوديه والعربيه امس
احد نجومها الفنان فهد الحيان اللي توفي
اثر سكته قلبيه مفاجئه عن عمر 52 سنه عبد
العزيز شقيق الفنان الراحل كشف للعربيه
تفاصيل اللحظات الاخيره من حياه شقيق فقال
انه ما كان بيشكو من اي مشاكل صحيه قبل
وفاته انه دخل ينام عادي ولما دخلوا يصحوه
ما صحيوا وفاه الراحل فهد الحياه مجددت
الكلام عن السكتات القلبيه المفاجئه او
كثير ناس اونلاين جلسه بتقول انه وفاه
الفجاه زادت مؤخرا فهل هي فعلا زادت ولا
احنا اللي صرنا نسمع عن هذه الحالات اكثر
ولا في شيء فعلا في اسلوب الحياه تغير
وسبب زياده في الوفيات المبكره خلونا
نستغل وجود دكتور اسلام معانا ونستفسر منه
دكتور اسلام خليني ارجعلك على هذا الموضوع
يعني في الفتره الاخيره نحن صايرين بنسمع
عن الناس يعني لازالوا انه يعني خلينا
نقول شباب او يعني في منتصف العمر وما الى
ذلك وبيتعرض وكده فجاه بيتوفوا وبعدين
بيقال انه مثلا سكته قلبيه او ما الى ذلك
هل فعلا الموضوع زايد ولا فيش شيء صاير
السؤال رائع جدا سيدتي
النوبات القلبيه انا باعتقادي في زياد في
زياده
هلا حتقول لي والله زمان ما كان عندهم طرق
للتشخيص ممكن وارد هذا الكلام وعن
احصائيات ادقوا الان الميديا بتساعد على
الوصول الاخبار لكن هي في زياده وهذا مثبت
علميا وزياده في الاعمار الصغيره اللي هم
خلينا نقول يعني خلينا نقول ابتداء من
العقد الرابع من العمر
فصاعدا لما نقول اعمار اربعين وخمسين سنه
هي بصراحه للاسف الاعمار المستهدفه في
البوفيات المفاجئه وتحديدا نوبات القلب او
توقف القلب او جلطات القلب فهي في ازدياد
حتسالي ليش والسؤال كثير مهم الك ولا
للساده المشاهدين انه الزياده سببها طبيعه
نمط الحياه تبعنا الان التلف عن السابق
اختلف اختلاف كلي بطلنا اول اشي في عنا
اضرار بيئيه في عنا اضرار
يوميا دخان وسجائر والارجيله في مجتمعاتنا
منتشر وبشكل ضخم وكبير يؤدي هذا الافراط
بتناول النيكوتين والتدخين يؤدي الى وفيات
مفاجئه في الاعمار الصغيره
احد الاسباب المحفزه لجلطات او نوبات
القلب الستريس وبتعرفي انت كيف نمط الحياه
الان الان كل في عجول الكل يعني صح دكتور
بس نحن يعني هذه الاشياء حتى كمان ممكن
تسبب الوفاه لكبار السن بس نحن اللي
ملاحظينه انه الصغار تحديدا اللي هم كان
عندهم قابليه او يعني عنا قابليه لمقاومه
الامراض وما الى ذلك اكثر فهدول تحديدا
بيتعرضوا لنفس الستريس اللي بيتعرضوا له
الكبار بيدخنوا زي ما الكبار بيدقنوا على
عكس الكبار بيدخنوا فتره اطول فايش السر
في الصغار
رائع جدا برضو سؤالك سيدتي
دكتور انا معجبه فيك جدا انت رائع يا
دكتور لاني عجبتك كل اسئلتي فانت رائع
كمان هلا شو في الاسئله اللي بيطرحوها
الناس يعني صحيح بحترم اسئلتك لانه هذه
الاسئله بيطرحوها
بجلطه وما يموت ممكن بس تضعف عضله القلب
فاضله بكونوا شرايينه ما فيهم اشي اسمه
ما بيكونوا مفرعين فرعات جانبيه بحيث انها
تساعده على وصول الدم اذا سكر الشريان
الرئيسي كبار السن بمرور الوقت بصير عندهم
تضيقات مثل الشجره هذا الشريان يتفرع لما
يعطي فروع جانبيه لو سكر الشريان الرئيسي
ما زال هذا الانسان يعني له بالعمر بقيه
لانه يوصل دم من خلال الشرايين الفرعيه
عند الصغير لا تنمو الشرايين الفرعيه
بالعكس هو يعتمد فقط الاعتماد على الشريان
الرئيسي اذا تسكر او اغلق او ان صار له
انسداد يؤدي الى وفاه مفاجاه بسبب
الكهرباء المفرطه بالقلب الانسان الكبير
في العمر تدريجيا بسبب تصلب الشرايين
عنده فروع جانبيه من الشرايين الرئيسيه
يعد الى وصول دم فحتى لو صابوا جلطه مسكين
الكبير في العمر لا ممكن انه يعيش وبس
يصاب بضعف في الجانب اللي ما وصلوا الدم
من كلامك دكتور اسلام انه بالنسبه للصغار
وموت الفجاه تغيير نمط الحياه هو الحل
الوحيد يعني
بصراحه النوم اغلب صغار السن ساعات النوم
قليله الافراط في الدخان الافراط في
التوتر الهرمونات الزائده عن حاجتها نمط
الحياه ما فيش حرق كولسترول عالي جدا
اعتماد على وجبات سريعه هذه اسباب كثيره
سيدتي
يعني انما ابغى اقول لك كل الزملاء هنا
نهاره الكل عايش اسلوب الحياه هذا للاسف
طيب
معك حق معك حق معك حق ويعني الله يعيننا
بس ان شاء الله ايه والله يعني دايما نقدر
نغير اسلوب حياتنا لاسلوب حياه اكثر صحيه
وهي فعلا هذه الرساله المهمه وشكرا لك على
كل المعلومات المفيده اللي شاركتنا معها
في هذه الفقره كان معنا الدكتور اسلام ابو
سيدو استشاري امراض القلب وزميل الكليه
الامريكيه للامراض القلب والشرايين شكرا
لك
من وقت تداول الخبر وفاه فهد الحيان اسمه
ستار ترند سواء على تويتر او جوجل او
فيسبوك او غيره والكثير من النجوم
والمسؤولين تسابقوا للتعزيه في الراحل
والترحم عليه
انطلق في التمثيل من اوائل التسعينات
وبرصيد وعشرات الاعمال ابرزها طاش ما طاش
وغشم ومع تداول الخبر وفاه المغردين بداوا
في تداول مقاطع من اعماله اللي اضحكت
الجمهور لسنوات
اقول الشرهه ما هي مهيب عليكم
نشرها على اللي يموت عندكم تقلع فيها
ما بتوفي ما بتوفي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا من زمان
بس لما تعرفت على سعيدان وعليا
[موسيقى]
ومشاجرين
قلبي يا ابوي بس يا عمري بس
[موسيقى]
ومن المقاطع المتداوله بكثره كمان اخر
ظهور للراحل واللي كان عبر حسابه على تيك
توك في عيد الفطر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وغير حساباته الناس وصلت حتى لحساب ابنه
الراحل على تيك توك وتداوله كثير من
المواقع او المواقف اللي كانت بتنزلها مع
والدها وحقيقه هذه المقاطع يعني مؤثره جدا
ورحم الله طبعا الفنان الراحل وتعازينا
لاسرته
[موسيقى]
كان في جح جح قابلني يا اصحابي ابي
وطاحت الجحه
[موسيقى]